comme il l'a fait sur terre depuis bien
plus longtemps avec les résultats
désastreux que l'on sait
les hommes constitue l'une des dernières
espèces animales à être apparu sur notre
planète il ya seulement vingt mille ans
ils n'étaient encore que des chasseurs
nomades
tout récemment encore les eskimos
parcourait la glace à la recherche des
phoques dans les jungles amazonienne les
indiens ont appris où trouver les
éléments indispensables à leur
subsistance dans les déserts d'afrique
du sud
les bushmen résiste à la sécheresse en
prélevant le peu d'eau ou que peuvent
leur fournir les racines où il est il
des plantes pendant des millions
d'années les ancêtres de l'homme ont
vécu de cueillette et de chasse il y a
dix mille ans seulement
toutes les communautés humaines ne
vivait pas autrement dans ces forêts du
moyen orient
il y a largement de quoi se nourrir des
pistaches des amendes sauvage des glands
et toutes sortes de bêtes il y a dix
mille ans les animaux sauvages abondait
il y avait des chèvres des ports des
chevaux des taureaux sauvages des
gazelles mais malgré tout cela la vie
était dure
des pluies torrentielles des nuits
glaciales et des journées torrides et
puis il y à 9000 à environ tout a changé
l'homme a fait un pas décisif jusqu
alors comme tous les animaux il avait
été conditionnée par son environnement
il avait été le jouet des éléments à
partir de ce moment là il a décidé de
maîtriser cet environnement il a
commencé à plier la nature a ses
exigences à la domestique et à son
profit cette vallée a été un des foyers
de ce processus abeda en jordanie
on a retrouvé les vestiges d'un des
premiers villages construits par l'homme
non plus un campement mais un habitat
permanent avec des rues des maisons et
des quartiers
ces constructions avaient des fondations
solides
le sol et les murs étaient recouverts
d'un plâtre demont et de chaux arrimé au
mur des piliers supportait un toit de
chaume
ces gens avaient bâti une maison presque
confortable qu'il est protégé de la
pluie et du soleil un foyer où les
maires pouvaient mettre au monde leur
enfant en relative sécurité
ici on a retrouvé beaucoup de melun
destiné à moudre une sorte d'orge
sauvage qui poussait dans la région
elles ont servi également à moudre les
grains d'une autre plante elle aussi
sauvage à l'époque le blé dur
solidement confortablement installés ici
les habitants se découragèrent
rapidement d'aller battre la campagne au
hasard pour récolter le blé l'orge et
d'autres céréales comme il le faisait
depuis des siècles et il finir par
comprendre l'intérêt de ce même eux
mêmes de cultiver la terre autour de
leur village il pouvait ainsi la
surveiller ils pouvaient s'assurer
qu'elle ne serait pas saccagé par les
animaux sauvages
peu à peu ils perfectionner leur culture
ils augmentaient les rendements et c'est
ainsi qu'il de vars les premiers
véritables agriculteurs on a également
trouvé ici beaucoup d'ossements de
chèvre que les habitants de beda avait
semble-t-il réussi à apprivoiser et à
faire se reproduire en captivité les
procédés de domestication et les animaux
domestiques eux mêmes ont alors
lentement gagner l'europe il y à 7000
ans les peuplades vivant dans la france
actuelle élevait déjà leur bétail mille
ans plus tard leurs techniques et les
gardiens de troupeaux de même
traverser la manche pour gagner
l'angleterre
ils ont débarqué ici quelque part dans
le sud de l'île mais la terre qu'il
découvrira lors ne ressemblaient pas à
celles ci à l'époque la région était
presque entièrement boisé les animaux
sauvages abondait ont leur mena une
chasse intensive le cochon sauvage était
comestible mais il fut domestiqué et la
race d'origine s'était ni les loups trop
dangereux furent exterminés ont capturé
les castors pour leur fourrure vers le
xiiie siècle eux aussi disparu
les élans eux avaient été tués jusqu'au
dernier avant même la conquête romaine
les plus puissants animaux
préhistoriques de ces forêts étaient les
aurochs il semble qu'ils aient fait
l'objet d'une sorte de culte on retrouve
leur effigie sur les murs des cavernes
en france notamment
ce sont les ancêtres des bovins
domestique certains de leurs lointains
descendants vivent encore dans les monts
chevio au nord de l'angleterre
hachey lingam vers le xiiie siècle un
troupeau fut parqués dans un grand
enclos les hommes les ont laissés depuis
lors en presque totale indépendance
ces animaux ressemble sans doute à ceux
qui arrêtent en liberté à l'époque
romaine très différents de ce qui est
devenu la gentil vaches frisonnes
d'aujourd'hui après avoir transformé
l'animal sauvage en animal a
relativement docile les fermiers ont
utilisé les mêmes techniques pour
modifier sa morphologie elle-même le but
final étant évidemment de produire un
maximum de viande c'est jolie peinture
commandité par deux fiers éleveurs du
siècle dernier révèle clairement les
canons de la race bovine à l'époque ils
n'ont pas fondamentalement changé
de nos jours les pattes des taureaux
sont à ce point chétive qu'elle ne leur
permettent pas de chasser un rival
beaucoup n'ont même plus de cornes pour
affirmer leur virilité
à quoi bon d'ailleurs puisque la
fréquentation des vaches elles mêmes
leur est interdite
on prélève leur sperme artificiellement
et il l'est féconde à l'autre bout du
monde sans même quitter leur étable
soigneusement gaver ses bovins peuvent
grossir d'un kilo par jour et sera
trouvée à l'abattoir en moins d'un an
ces nouvelles races de cochon
descendants directs des sangliers de nos
forêts grandissent cinq fois plus vite
que leurs cousins sauvages en six mois
ils sont bons à abattre
ces dindes ne ressemble plus guère à
celles qui vivaient autrefois en liberté
en amérique centrale
on les produit en masse par insémination
artificielle
nos poules descendante lointaine
d'oiseaux des jungles asiatiques ont été
convertis en pondeuses intensive à 300 e
par an les mêmes techniques de
production sélective sont appliqués à
nos légumes originaires du monde entier
la pomme de terre provient des andes où
elle était cultivée déjà par les incas
le poids est originaire d'italie où on
le consommer dès le xvième siècle les
fèves viennent du mexique
la rhubarbe de chine la betterave
d'allemagne et ce légume s'ils étaient
cultivés au septième siècle en
afghanistan ont le transplantant en
afrique du nord les morts l'a mené en
europe où les hollandais s'en firent une
spécialité c'est la carotte d'autres
végétaux qui interviennent pour une part
essentielle dans l'alimentation humaine
ne pousse cependant pas dans nos
potagers où il passait pour de mauvaises
herbes
le riz commence à être cultivée en asie
il y à 7000 ans au moment où le blé
commencé à l'être dans le bassin
méditerranéen
au fil des siècles on perfectionna les
techniques de production dans des
terrasses inondées au point que le riz
se récoltent aujourd'hui plusieurs fois
par an
en proliférant l'humanité à démultiplier
les zones cultivées
aujourd'hui 11 % des terres arables sont
destinés à la seule culture du riz dont
dépend l'alimentation de la moitié de la
population du globe
en occident les goûts alimentaires en
matière d'herbacées même s'ils ont
évolué ont des origines quasiment
préhistorique le blé aujourd'hui tous de
rue les techniques sélective on
rentabiliser la production
en un demi siècle le volume des récoltes
a doublé et aujourd'hui ces tiges
supporte dix fois plus de grain que
celle qui pousse encore à l'état sauvage
dans les terres désertiques du
moyen-orient cette évolution a cependant
un prix à blaye tel que celui ci ne peut
se reproduire sans l'intervention de
l'homme
on l'a immunisé contre des maladies
telles que la moisissure ou le charbon
les céréales mais c'est maladie elle
même évolué elle menace les nouvelles
espèces
au point que les agriculteurs doivent
sans changer tous les dix ans de nos
jours ne pousse plus aux états unis que
quatre familles de blé si les
producteurs ne réussissent pas à
développer d'autres croisement au départ
d'espèces sauvages l'alimentation du
monde occidental tout entier pourrait
être menacée subvenir aux besoins sans
cesse croissants de l'humanité
d'immenses étendues les plus fertiles de
la planète ont été convertis en terre de
culture
cette transformation entraîner la
disparition de centaines d'espèces
d'insectes et d'autres petites créatures
l'être humain ainsi exclu sur des
milliers de kilomètres carrés
d'innombrables formes de vie en
façonnant la terre en introduisant avec
la monoculture un nouvel environnement
l'homme a créé ici et là de nouveaux
univers terrestre dont il est le maître
absolu
ceci pourrait être considéré comme un
autre jean de monoculture l' espèce qui
prolifère ici est celle de l'homo
sapiens on pourrait supposer que les
plantes et les animaux n'ont plus leur
place dans un tel environnement
c'est faux beaucoup de citadins aspire
semble-t-il à la compagnie d'autres
créatures vivantes mais bien entendu ils
ont une fois de plus voulu adapter ses
compagnons à leurs caprices et à leur
fantaisie en altérant leur taille leur
fourrure et même leur odorat
d'autres organismes vivants ont
découvert que les villes ne leur était
pas fatalement interdite
au fond si une coulée de lave
apparemment stérile peut finir par être
colonisé pourquoi pas l'asphalt d'une
rue au xviiie siècle un botaniste
recueilli nerb de saint jacques ou
jacoby qui poussait sur les pentes de
l'etna
il lui prit la fantaisie de la ramener à
oxford pour tenter de la cultiver dans
un jardin botanique
soixante ans plus tard l'herbe avait
prospéré sur les murs du collège
elle s'y cantonne à un certain temps et
puis au 19e siècle l'angleterre commença
à se couvrir de lignes de chemin de fer
les moellons sur lesquels étaient posés
les rails convenait tout à fait à
l'herbe de saint jacques
c'est pourquoi elle continue d'y fleurir
de nos jours
quelques animaux sauvages ont également
réussi à s'adapter à cet environnement
créée par l'homme
en apparence au style des loutres de mer
nages ainsi joyeusement dans les ports
de californie les chiens de prairie
exclus de leur domaine par les fermiers
ont trouvé de nouveaux habitats au coeur
même des villes de même que les renards
qui se nourrissent dans les poubelles
éloges sur les toits de banlieue dans le
sud ouest des états unis
les pics de californie continue de
stocker des glands dans les troncs de
sapins même si ceux ci ont été
transformés en poteaux télégraphiques
les hirondelles ont appris depuis
longtemps à exploiter les gouttières
pour y établir leur nid peu d'entre
elles nichent encore ailleurs mais ces
animaux urbains ne sont pas tous les
bienvenus
ces insectes ou ces mammifères un peu
trop familier prétendent nous disputer
notre nourriture d'autres s'attaquent à
nos biens alors c'est la guerre tous ces
animaux ne font pas seulement des
razzias dans nos garde manger ils sont
également susceptibles de répandre des
maladies et nous sommes obligés d'en
contrôler la prolifération nous les
attrapons dans des pièges où nous les
ont empoisonnés
si nous voulons survivre dans les
grandes concentrations urbaines que nous
nous sommes créées
nous devons gérer les communautés
animales et végétales qui s'y
développent
nous devons évacuer de nos cités
l'énorme quantité d'ordures que nous
produisons new york produit 22 mille
tonnes de déchets par jour
la moitié est chargé sur des péniches
qui descendent l'hudson pour être
déversée sur staten island
les déchets sont déposés en couches d'un
mètre d'épaisseur sur 60 m de largeur
chaque jour ces couches avance de 30
mètres et lorsque la surface est
totalement recouverte on re dépose par
dessus une nouvelle couche
mais cette manière de procéder et
coûteuse lorsqu'on en trouve une plus
économique
on n'hésite pas à l'utiliser quelles
qu'en soient les conséquences
pourvu que nous ne l'ayons plus sous le
nez ou sous les yeux peu nous importe ce
que deviennent nos ordures
nous sommes persuadés que la terre est
bien assez grande pour résorber tous nos
poison le déversé une quantité énorme de
déchets chimiques et de détergents dans
nos rivières
si les eaux de lessive ont une utilité
dans un évier en milieu naturel
elles peuvent être fatales aux plantes
et aux poissons
en dépit de tout c'est la réglementation
nous déversons du pétrole dans la mer
au point qu'aujourd'hui il n'est
pratiquement plus un coin d'océan si
éloigné soit-il où l'on ne rencontre ici
ou là une nappe de mazout
nous polluons même l'air que nous
respirons les gaz d'échappement de nos
moteurs empoisonne l'atmosphère de nos
villes
les vapeur qui s'échappe des tours de
refroidissement d'une centrale
électrique sont relativement sans danger
mais les gaz de combustion du charbon ou
du pétrole ne le sont certainement pas
nous avons trouvée à ce problème une
solution élémentaire nous construisons
des cheminées de plus en plus hautes
afin que leur fumée soit évacué le plus
loin possible
elles ne disparaissent évidemment pas
pour autant emportée par les vents elles
vont se déposer dans des régions parfois
éloignées de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres
ces dernières années dans la plupart des
lacs de scandinavie l'acidité de l'eau a
augmenté à un point tel que plus un
animal plus une plante ne peut y vivre
rien qu'en norvège il y a aujourd'hui 18
sans l'accent poissons et des centaines
d'autres qui sont en voie de connaître
le même sort
aucune partie du monde n'est à l'abri
des imprudences de l'homme ces îles au
large du pérou donne à première vue une
image de fertilité et de succès et
écologique
elle abrite une grande variété d'oiseaux
de mer des pélicans des fous des sternes
et des mouettes
mais il ya 35 ans un autre oiseau ville
est ici une espèce de cormorans appelé
gwan est à l'époque où ces images ont
été filmées dans les années 50
plus de 5 millions de gwan est nichée
sur une seule de ces îles cet oiseau se
nourrit exclusivement dans le choix il
rejette une grande proportion du poisson
digérer sous forme de guano les pluies
ici sont rares le guano n'est pas
dissout par l'eau ils s'accumulent sur
les rochers or il ya un siècle on
s'aperçut que cette substance organique
constituait un fertilisant d'une
richesse incomparable
le guano fut récolté systématiquement
est vendu au prix fort et le gua n'est
devin l'oiseau le plus rentable du monde
mais dans les années 50 se développant
en europe la fabrication des
fertilisants chimiques
le prix du guano chuta et les
populations qui en vivaient commencèrent
à récolter non plus le guano mais les
anchois en une seule année
on empêche à 14 millions de tonnes
vendues comme nourriture pour bétail
cette pêche intensive à main rapidement
la quasi-disparition des anchois dans
ces eaux et par voie de conséquence un
effondrement de la population des
cormorans gwan est
à l'heure actuelle la population des
cormorans sur cette île est tombé à 2 %
de ce qu'elle était il ya 35 ans et
c'est murray qui aurait été entièrement
recouvert de guano en deux ans non
accumulent plus aujourd'hui qu'une
couche infime mais les cormorans ne
laisse pas tomber le guano que sur terre
l'essentiel se dépose en mer il y
fertilise les eaux il permet le
développement les plantes flottantes
donc du plancton qui sert de nourriture
aux anchois
ainsi le cercle est bouclée si vous avez
moins d'anchois vous aurez moins de
cormorans mais si vous avez moins de
cormorans vous aurez aussi - d'anchois
sans compter que les anchois ne servent
pas de nourriture qu'aux seuls cormorans
mais à d'autres espèces de poissons
comme les bars et les temps
conclusion cet acte de surpêche et
réfléchi il y à 35 ans a entraîné pour
cette région la perte des anchois des
cormorans du guano et des poissons mer
c'est un coup fatal pour l'économie
péruvienne